welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of top gun
maverick as much as i love analyzing
marvel and star wars here as a military
brat from a family full of navy pilots
this highway back to the danger zone was
the most fun i had in a movie theater
this year with fun callbacks to the 1986
tony scott film and a mission that is
essentially the star wars trench run so
let us break down all the cool stuff you
missed the film opens with the same
exact text that opened the 1986 film the
history of the fighter weapons school
except now it includes and women and
instead of cutting to top gun we cut to
top gun maverick we also have the same
iconic harold fault meyer theme music
this movie's director joseph kaczynski
uses the same aircraft carrier flight
deck imagery except instead of a6s and
f14s from the 86 movie we now see f-18s
and f-35s and we quickly switched to
kenny loggins danger zone i can't
believe it took nearly two minutes to
get there i nearly walked out we start
with captain pete mitchell maverick and
his mojave desert hanger repairing a
world war ii p51 mustang which in real
life is tom cruise's own personal
airplane that madman tom cruise insisted
all of the action in this movie was shot
with real aircraft no cgi and it shows
the dogfighting imagery is freaking
great in this film especially when you
see it in imax you'll notice maverick's
flight jacket has the patches of the
flags of japan and taiwan restored after
they were scrubbed out of a 2019 trailer
mitchell wore this jacket in the 86 film
as a tribute to his late father
meanwhile i wear my dad's flight jacket
to look cool at themed movie parties i
am definitely the least cool boss
maverick is now a test pilot trying to
reach mach 10 with the darkstar
hypersonic jet you could interpret this
whole movie as dying visions of maverick
when he pushed the dark star too far and
crashed it and in this fantasy maverick
is the one pilot in the world leading an
impossible mission to victory with the
son of his dead wingman goose the sun
now back in goose's seat of an f-14 and
about that i prefer to live in a world
where mav gets away with an ego writing
checks his body can cash and of course
this mach 10 mission is a bit of a
callback to the 86 film when charlie
told him you're not gonna be happy
unless you're going mach 2 with your
hair on fire you know that i like how
matt uses the dark star to buzz rear
admiral hammer and actually later in
that 14. buzz this is the tower on vice
admiral cyclone buzzing the tower being
the stunt that got him in trouble at the
beginning of the 86 film and he does
throughout the movie and just like in
that 86 film maverick stunt gets him
sent to the top gun school this time as
an instructor something he told
commander stinger he wanted to do when
he got older where do you think you want
to go
i thought of being an instructor sir
top gun
yes sir
god help us
once he gets back to san diego he once
again tries to outrun a jet on his
motorcycle in the 86 film it was an 85
kawasaki ninja this time at 2019
kawasaki ninja h2 carbon at the bar he
meets penny benjamin played by jennifer
connelly the same admiral's daughter
mentioned at the beginning of the 86
film with a history of high speed passes
over five air control towers and one
admiral's daughter
penny benjamin if you listen close to
the music playing in the scene it's
david bowie's let's dance back in the
year 1986 while tom cruise was in top
gun that same year jennifer connelly was
in labyrinth dancing with david bowie
penny lives in the same san diego
neighborhood and house where charlie
lived in the 86 film at the end of that
movie she drives a classic porsche just
like charlie did because maverick will
only [ __ ] women who drive this car we
meet the younger crop of pilots
including miles teller as lieutenant
bradley rooster bradshaw goose's son
whom we saw as a kid sitting on a piano
in the 86 film his callsign rooster
sticking with the bird theme he plays
goodness gracious great balls of fire
wearing aviators just like his dad did
in that film he has a rivalry with
hangman hangman essentially the iceman
of this movie when hangman picks a song
in the jukebox he hits eight and six and
now to 86 and when they toss out
maverick for his card getting declined
penny calls it getting 86. now in that
86 film maverick felt embarrassed when
the person he messed with at the bar
charlie turned out to be the consultant
instructor of his class now hangman
feels embarrassed to realize the guy he
threw out of the bar is his instructor
maverick now the bar of this movie is
called the hard deck which actually came
up a lot in the 86 film as the altitude
mav broke the rules by flying under
breaking the rules of engagement but in
this movie the hard deck is reversed the
mission is to fly beneath the hard deck
to avoid detection by the radar and the
surface-to-air missiles now as you've
been watching this video wouldn't it
have been great if you could have been
making some money just by having
something run in the background well
thanks to honeygain for sponsoring this
video honeygain is an app that makes you
cash or just keeping it running in the
background they're not promising to pay
all your bills or anything but it is
enough money to cover your netflix
subscription every month or maybe buy
you and a friend some tasty beverages
here's how it works install any game on
your device and that's it you're making
money just by sharing your internet
connection it uses the internet to
gather bits of information from the web
like the best prices on airline tickets
honeygain doesn't have any effect on
your internet experience it doesn't
collect any personal data or require any
device storage and whenever you have 20
withdrawal your money to paypal or
bitcoin and go buy your buddy that
beverage they're thirsty you can also
withdraw into a jmpt cryptocurrency it
works on windows mac os and android
devices so use code rockstars 5 when
signing up or click the link in the
description down below and get 5 added
to your account and they're going to
pick one person to get fifty dollars
worth of honey gained credits
transferred to their account who uses
our promo code and gets three people to
sign up via their own referral code see
details in the description and thanks
again honey game for sponsoring this
video now during this amazing training
montage maverick inverts his jet so that
his cockpit is upside down above theirs
the same move mav does to the enemy migs
in the 86 film the pilot fanboy has his
call sign written on his helmet in the
same typeface as the title for star trek
another paramount property now as in
that film the enemy is an unspecified
rogue state 1986 despite the jets flying
around the indian ocean the enemy is
basically north korea they don't ever
say it but like that's kind of who it is
in this movie the enemy is a country
that is trying to get nuclear capability
the target being a uranium enrichment
facility trying to make weapons grade
uranium and the country has snowy
mountains that borders the ocean now it
is never meant to be clearly identified
but the country does have f-14s and in
real life iran bought 80 f-14s in 1978
right before the shah was ousted by
ayatollah kamini and iran has been
trying to get nuclear capabilities as of
this taping has not gotten there yet so
really the country of iran is the
closest analog in this movie even if its
border with the gulf of oman doesn't
have snow-capped mountains like this
border does and of course as with the 86
film we get a shirtless beach sports
montage before it was volleyball now it
is football val kilmer cameos in this
movie is admiral tom iceman kazansky
kilmer in real life was diagnosed with
throat cancer in 2014 and after
tracheotomy lost his voice but the
production was able to use ai technology
to recreate his voice for just a few
lines he types on his screen it's time
to let go which for me at least evoked
the rescue swimmer telly maverick as he
held goose's body you gotta let him go
the mission of this film very closely
mirrors the trench run of star wars
1977. the pilots have to fly low through
a narrow canyon evading deadly gunner
towers and faceless enemy pilots so that
they can fire a missile into an
impossibly narrow target and after the
laser sight jams rooster has to eyeball
the target to fire the missile in the
hole just like luke does when he turns
off his sight maven roosters speak to
goose's ghost they talk to me goose just
like the ghost of obi-wan kenobi tells
luke to use the force and considering
maverick is really the uncle figure who
denied rooster's application of the
naval academy to avoid him turning out
like his old man you could look at this
movie as star wars starring on glowing
there are just several great callbacks
throughout the film like mav telling
rooster don't think like mavs saying in
the 86 film if you think
you're dead and after they crash in
enemy territory and steal an f-14 and
end up in a dogfight with rooster
sitting in goose's seat in the same kind
of aircraft rooster says this line of
mavs come on mav do some of that pilot
[ __ ] which is the same thing goose tells
maverick an 86 film and then when they
get the drop on the enemy fighter mav
says too close for missiles switching to
guns and we get this close-up of mavs
switching the thumbstick from missiles
to guns and there's a sticker label on
that stick saying missiles and guns
which is hilarious because this is not
how an f-14 interior is actually set up
they just directly copied the 1986 movie
prop f-14 controls from that movie where
they had put a sticker in there they
just used the same kind of shot so that
you knew when he was switching and in
the climax of the film the way maverick
in the 86 film had to hold back
initially on the mission and then later
join in to assist iceman in the dogfight
now hangman completes his arc of not
leaving his wingman out to dry by saving
mav in rooster here in this dogfight and
then in the final scene of the film
before lady gaga comes in with her song
we see mav back repairing his p-51
mustang except now you can see his
flight helmet sitting on the shelf of
his hanger a little detail signalling
the man has finally retired if you're
new here to new rockstars we love to
break down and analyze all the best
movies everything you love so be sure to
subscribe to new rockstars here on
youtube and you can follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos be sure
to follow new rockstars and socials as
well thank you so much for watching bye
[Music]
you